on a passé notre première me dont la
villa vous savez là bas alors je vous le
dis il fait nuit à 14 heures quatre
danseurs t fracasse complètement et vous
allez voir la première nuit ils ont tous
dormi dans leurs chambres respectives
sauf un qui acquit dû quitter sa chambre
regardez le kessel
[Musique]
personne à ses cheveux en plus c'est
mieux mais c'est mon corps il affrontera
faudra combien des dangers des personnes
sans que c'est mon petit âge je sais pas
menti elles elles aiment plus c'est mon
pote c'est fort
et là je vais je vais vraiment trop bas
et les sépare les économies génèrent
tout ton corps est très acidifier quant
à rennes et s'il y avait une meuf là
dessus c'est très bizarre pas un parfum
de fin bref non non ça c'est pas la
donne en plus amenés samimi 1 c1
ça me tue pas qu'il met des vides de
sens et notre chambre il a dû courir
c'est trop content des temps des cerises
à et pourquoi ça m'attire 17h cochet 19
heures et bien prenons logiciel je suis
gentil qui est vraiment monsieur même sa
vision nocturne et j'ai pas eu d'ordre
plutôt comment alors
c'est parti bah oui j'en miami gens qui
vont peut-être
[Applaudissements]
seul noël en famille
[Musique]
méditez là si les gars quand tu sors ta
100 parce que je dors devant ta chambre
parce que ça pue trop lapin ça pue à
vomir non mais c'est tout simplement
quand tu sors si tu sors tu fais
attention
merci un débat qui est mon mari
c'est tout du moment
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
non non non non mais là tu t'es trompé
d'une c et nuit le cassis meilleurs
intellectuels est sectionnée non mais
c'est pour contagieuse humide on la sait
comment tu les avais vus sur l'émission
je le mets dans un coup de mou pape se
creuse sa communication commune où elles
sont parfois vraiment vraiment ça sent
très fort a gagné
j'ordonne à chanter alors bon il fallut
d'un couloir
à à arrêter de marcher mer dans la
lumière
fish chine
[Applaudissements]